Hale no red background but I do have a
movie review
finally super so I'm in California I saw
screening a super and if you don't know
what super is is the story of Rainn
Wilson aka Dwight Schrute from the
office who loses his wife Liv Tyler to
Kevin Bacon aka mr. douchebag and he
plays douchebag really well you see the
guy and you're like that's a douche
so then Rainn Wilson believes he has
been touched by God with the purpose of
becoming the superhero of the Crimson
bolt after that is kind of what you
think it should be if an average guy
became a superhero but kind of not
because he's actually pretty dark it's
like if Dwight from the office became
the Punisher he bludgeons people with a
wrench if he doesn't kill him yeah
they're not in good shape are you not
laughing already
that's awesome it was built on like a
ham sandwich budget so it's like
Napoleon Dynamite meets kick-ass with a
little bit of falling down in it with a
cameo by Nathan Fillion which always
adds awesome to anything do you think
our eyes pretty funny it's going on and
then something happens where you're like
holy [ __ ] that was so violent you think
you've seen it all and then the movie
gets bloody as [ __ ] which again is
always fun it's like kick-ass but darker
I don't know if it's more violent than
kick-ass but it is darker than kick-ass
like he needs a weapon so he's tossing
around what weapon should I use how
should I get a weapon and then he says
that'll do cool and then the two minutes
after that is just a montage of Awesome
and win in terms of bloody and
unapologetic this is probably the most
unapologetic superhero movie that I have
ever seen
kick-ass was awesome and it was great it
still felt like a comic book movie but
like just took it over the top which
made it cool but super was just really
bloody like bludgeons guys with that
big-ass wrench people who deserve it
though you know
and I liked Ellen Page in it she's
really fun like Ellen Page is like the
nerdiest tomboy who's still like really
cute works for this role I liked her in
the movie she was a bit enthusiastic but
it was funny
and then there were scenes of like
badassery [ __ ] goes down at a point
you're like that is actually really
badass my biggest regret in the movie is
that someone dies I don't think they
needed to die at least not in the
anti-climatic way that they died maybe
I'm a sucker for a common and basic
formula I don't know but I just don't
think the character needed to die that's
one of those things for you like that's
hard to say it just is but all in all
the movies funny as hell is
unapologetically
like I said it's [ __ ] bloody if you
like any or all of those three you'll
like it and nathan fillion winning i
gotta stop saying that [ __ ] I really
like the moving then the end happens and
like the ends going and then the movie's
wrapping up and Rainn Wilson is doing a
voiceover and it's really good for some
messed up reason I almost wanted to cry
I don't know I just did so I don't know
how wide a release this movie's gonna
get but I thought it was a good time no
alcohol required whatsoever it's not for
everyone it's just not like there were
people who liked kick-ass that probably
will not like this movie but I
personally had a good time with it dude
gets his head like split with a wrench
dude so as my stay in California comes
to a close I'm getting back into my
movie reviews I get back on Monday I'm
gonna watch all the movies I can that I
missed and in the days after that you're
gonna get a lot of [ __ ] from me Rango
Adjustment Bureau battle Los Angeles
this stuff I missed feel like I've been
like on Pluto I might as well have been
on Pluto but if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more